you're the guy we want to talk to about
this how's his legacy well you know he
he was a creative to show so he created
two late-night shows which is something
nobody really is done you know that's
successfully you know he succeeded or
knew he succeeded after Carson you know
holding the late-night show or Late Show
and then he went to CBS and created
another show and you know CBS was really
in dire straits in late night they had
nothing I mean they couldn't get
coverages they couldn't get clearances
they couldn't put up content so I think
that's his legacy I spoke to Howard
Stringer yesterday he signed David
Letterman to his contract at CBS he told
me his biggest concern was not that NBC
might keep Letterman in the stable his
biggest concern was Rupert Murdoch
because he said he didn't know what he
had up his sleeve was Fox ever in
contention for this he talked to a lot
of people he talked to Robert Iger at
ABC even though they had Nightline that
he respected Ted Koppel he didn't got to
move him out well 2002 there was a point
where he would there was he was being
wooed by ABC and then you know he backed
down and Andry up with CBS but you're
right Fox was a fledgling Network they
had Joan Rivers which failed in fact
they put on Joan Rivers before they put
anything in prime time they had Chevy
Chase and that failed so they they were
looking for something like a Letterman
but I don't think Letterman at that
stage would have gone to something as
you know not as solid as Fox at that
time you know I think would have gone to
something at CBS a much more established
network what about the switch from 12:30
to 11:30 I asked mr. stringer about that
too that's not an easy transition to
make because the audience tends to be
more conservative younger folks are up
at 12:30 at 1:30 in the morning now
folks our age so you're talking about a
conservative maybe it tends to skew
Midwestern audience it's 10:30 yeah it
is that sort of one of the things that
Johnny Carson told Lorne Michaels once
at Night Live was launched is you know
they're doing these monologues it's
10:30 in the Midwest I mean it's a
broad-based audience there but he was
able to make the adjustment he dressed
differently he just a little more
elegantly and he looked a little more
professional and he was able to woo the
you know the 11:30 audience which as you
point out there's more viewers and more
established or older viewers than 12:30
tell me about the deal that he did make
with Howard Stringer he got to keep some
rights there's world
Hanson volved oh yeah he did I think
that was part of the deal Johnny Carson
set this deal with NBC in the early 80s
where he retained control of the show
and when when Letterman was being wooed
by CBS that was one of the offers on the
table was that he would you know he'd be
able to control his own show and only
that he'd be able to control the show
after that at 12:30 which has been run
by Craig Ferguson up until last year
and then he created shows like Everybody
Loves Raymond was the show that came out
of worldwide pants so you know that was
a very lucrative business for that and
and one of the things Les Moonves said
wouldn't let him step down as CBS gets
control of that show because there's a
lot of money there so what happens with
worldwide pants now that's a very good
question I don't know what he's going to
do he says he's retiring from the show
but you know as an interview on Sunday
morning where he didn't quite say he's
still gonna be doing things but I think
that you know III don't think we're
gonna see too much of him I think he's
pretty much a reckless recluse and a
private person just the way that Johnny
Carson was I agree the Rolling Stone
article he wants to spend time with his
son Harry he has to go fishing in
Montana he wants to do things that our
son do yeah yeah well he's worth about
400 million dollars supposedly so I
don't think he has to do anything for
money he's been it's been a very
lucrative 33 year run for mr. Letterman
Stephen Colbert it's not as if he's
filling David Letterman shoes he's
Steven Colbert who's dressed
transforming late night in his own image
no that's true in fact he was at the CBS
up front last week you know everyone
thought David Letterman would show up
but but Stephen Colbert showed up and he
was really very funny I mean I think a
lot of people who worried about him you
know that that he played a character
with the same name and is that gonna
change I think he proved to the
advertisers that that you know he can
adjust and he's willing to talk to who
you know work with advertisers and and
do product placement and maybe get the
network a little angry from time to time
you know what it was interesting because
I was when I was prepping for the
interview with you when I was thinking
my own thoughts of David Letterman it's
like when you're a much younger man and
it's 12:30 to 1:30 you know you have a
job I wasn't working here
I got Pittsburgh you go home you've had
a long day you flip on David Letterman
and it's not David Letterman the talk
show hosted and I realize I don't mean
this to sound corny it is you you get to
spend an hour with you
he makes you laugh before you go to bed
that's what I took away for you know
that's what made him a broadcaster is is
that you know it's somebody you want to
spend time with just sensing with Johnny
Carson all the great people you know
it's it's still a personality driven day
part and if you're a baby boomer like it
like he was well he still is you know he
did stuff that you you would love to do
you know drop water melons from a
seven-story building put a camera
attached to a monkey and have him skate
around a race on elevators and things
like that so I mean he toned it down as
he got as it got a little bit older how
did the two Jimmy's fill the void or can
they well you know right now Jimmy
Fallon's in the lead and Jimmy Kimmel
was actually gonna go and repeat tonight
because he's in awe of David Letterman I
thought that was very respectful yeah it
isn't taking nothing away from Jimmy
Fallon or anybody else but the fact that
he said I'm gonna watch Dave I assume
everybody else I want them to so I'm
gonna air a repeat yeah I think this
will do a pretty big number I mean the
Leno finale last year his second fan I
did about fourteen point six million
viewers
I think this will do over 15 million
because of the longevity of his career
and and just you know the buzz around
around his departure but you know this
whole late night Jean renow is turning
online you know there's a lot of
fractionalization a lot of DVR playback
occurs it occurs at that hour and you
know obviously there's a there's a lot
of you know content Adult Swim if you
want to get young viewers watch Adult
Swim